ashley tisdale announced her pregnancy
how excited are you to watch her become
a bomb for the first time
oh my gosh it's so exciting i'm just i'm
so excited to
get back to la to sing to her baby
in her snake i am over the moon for her
and chris
they are just going to make such
incredible parents i cannot believe it
still but i'm very emotional and very
excited about it
will you be the godmother i'll be at
least a fairy godmother that's for sure
are you helping her with names at all no
she's already got that covered
oh she's already picked names i mean i
don't know
[Music]
listen i'm so happy you're here there's
no way we'd miss your coordination
and uh got you a little surprised i hope
it's okay that we're here
this movie was so much fun what was the
biggest
challenge for you in playing not two
characters this time but
three you know i pride myself on being a
professional
i'm showing up to set with my lines
memorized
and i would show up to set with my lines
memorized but by the end of the day
my brain was so shambled that i was like
i swear i know my lines i think i'm
losing my mind
just you know doing scenes with me
myself and i
it was like it was it was a lot
you want us to do what we switch back
you said you needed more time with kevin
do you really think we could pull it off
again does that mean you'll do it
you play regal royal so well have you
ever met
any of the royals in real life or did
you study any of them to sort of nail
margaret's
mannerisms i haven't met any of them
no i would love to meet the queen don't
get me wrong i grew up doing ballet
and i think that has always really
helped
me kind of exude that
royal essence no you carry yourself
differently and
i think that just like being in the
spotlight ever since i was
16 years old like you know you kind of
figure out a way how to carry yourself
and navigate through the world of
entertainment
you have been doing this forever and
there's this conversation between
margaret and kevin and he kind of says
to her you belong with someone of a
certain stature
someone who you can relate to for you i
mean having
to navigate dating in the public eye for
so long
do you feel like in your next
relationship you'll look for someone
more private or do you feel like you
need to be with someone who understands
what you know your girls open
no i mean i feel like at the end of the
day it's just about
having similar fundamentals and wanting
the same things like
i am not picky really
you should be picky i am i'm extremely
picky
but like i know what i want and i'm like
if someone comes into the picture and
can give me
all those things then great it doesn't
matter if they're in the public eye or
not if anything i would prefer them not
jumping
but we'll see would you ever let your
friends
or someone like ashley play cupid for
you
i mean 100 i'm like my
friends are my family and they care
about me
so much and i think that's what it
boiled down to for stacey and margaret
you know like she sees
her best friend who is taking on the
throne
she's about to become queen and she
knows how beautiful the relationship
that she had with kevin was
and you know like relationships are hard
they're complicated
but in the case for margaret and kevin
stacy wants them to give it another try
so i would totally let my friends be
like hey you should go for this
and set me up if anything where are you
at
this is my cousin the owner oh dear lord
there are three of them
why can't i pull the switch why should
people
watch this sequel three reasons it is
a really great movie for
this year i think we've all been through
so much
and it's a really wonderful
light-hearted fun
rom-com that's set in the holidays
and you know i think that we could all
use a bit of comfort and coziness and
this movie
will give you exactly that